hello uh we're here on the free camp.org
YouTube channel and we're about to
introduce a new JavaScript curriculum
from the from freec camp.org and I'm
here with Jessica Wilkins who's going to
be talking about it so Jessica could you
start off by talking a little bit about
yourself and your role at free camp and
spe specifically Your Role with this
JavaScript
curriculum sure yeah so I'm Jessica
Wilkins I'm a software developer based
out of Los Angeles California work
full-time now with Freo camp on the
curricul development team and so we just
launched the all new JavaScript Project
based curriculum there so you're going
to learn JavaScript by building projects
and so we have some really cool projects
that we've put together for you guys to
learn and I've been with freeo Camp
full-time since August of this year but
I've been working uh with Freo Camp as a
part-time and contributor for a few
years now I think since like 20120 wow
it's been a while uh but yeah that's a
little like introduction about me okay
yeah great so maybe you can talk even
more about this uh JavaScript curriculum
and what ex what is it like for for
Learners going through
it yeah yeah so for those of you who are
familiar with the uh older version of
the curriculum you learned JavaScript by
building are you going through
interactive challenges um but this
curriculum is different because you're
going to be learning JavaScript by
building actual projects so the first
project you're going to build is a role
playing game and you're going to learn
how to work with the Dom and you're
going to learn uh the basics of
JavaScript like working with arrays and
objects and variables and IFL statements
and functions and all of that and so you
start from scratch building out a little
bit of HTML a little bit of CSS and then
you dive straight into the JavaScript so
you learn how all three of those
languages work together to build
interactive web applications and so you
start with that and then you keep
building off of your knowledge you start
learning about event listers you start
learning about object oriented
programming by building a platformer
game and a dice game learning about
algorithmic thinking there's so many
cool things there's a lot of games
actually in this one that I realized
like we have a lot of games but games
are actually really cool because there's
so much logic behind games and there's
so many different things you have to
think about in terms of uh different
scenarios that the user has to go
through um and so I think the uh learner
is going to have a great time just uh
solidifying their JavaScript knowledge
uh by going through this interactive
Project based curriculum oh yeah it
sounds very comprehensive like who's the
target audience for this course who who
you who do you think will benefit the
most from
it yeah so this course is intended for
the absolute beginner so you don't have
to have any prior programming knowledge
or any prior knowledge of JavaScript U
so this assumes that you have zero
knowledge you coming from the responsive
web design certification or maybe you
have some brief exposure to HTML and CSS
but we're really just going to dive
straight into JavaScript and so you can
see how HTML CSS and JavaScript work
together um so only the first two
projects will we cover a little bit of
HTML and CSS have you write out some of
of the steps um and then the rest of the
projects will just Supply the HTML CSS
for you so you can just jump straight
into the the JavaScript and it just
assumes that you're an absolute beginner
you don't have to have any prior
programming knowledge or exposure to to
JavaScript to enjoy this
course okay great and I assume that this
was a a team effort to develop this
curriculum yeah yeah it definitely took
a lot of Us coming together it's been um
actually maybe I think at this point
almost years into the making from like
just conceptualizing and building out
the practice projects and kind of going
back and forth of what we wanted to
teach and which Concepts and where each
project was going to go and and building
out all the prototypes so we started off
with that a lot of discussions and
building out prototypes sharing ideas
reviewing each other's work and then
once we kind of solidified on those
prototypes then we started breaking them
down into steps and tests um and then
just going through the flow and making
sure all the projects work together as a
nice like cohesive curriculum there m
mhm well sounds pretty great so what are
viewers going to see in this video
here yeah so the purpose of this video
is just give a sneak peek of each of the
projects and so we'll start with the
very first one which is a role playing
game and it will just be me just kind of
walking through the final preview
project of what people are going to
build and then we jump into the next
project which is a calorie counter and
do the same thing where we show the
final preview of what people are going
to build and then we keep going from
there so the next one after that is an
interactive music player project and
then we have uh more projects along the
way and then I'll also show them uh what
they'll be building for the
certification projects um and the we
still have five certification projects
just like the other uh certifications of
free Coca but these are also going to
have all new uis and so people uh
Learners will get uh a lot of experience
just building out HTML CSS and
JavaScript so they can see how all three
of that uh comes together there and so
that's the whole thing is just to kind
of give a sneak peek on like what
they're going going to be building so
we're not really going to be like coding
along per se but we'll just dive
straight into the curriculum just to
show them like the final previews of
each of the project just to get people
really excited about what they're going
to be able to
build well that sounds great so let's
let's get on to the the rest of the
video
here all right so here we are at the
very first project of the allnew
JavaScript curriculum so make sure you
head over to freeco
camp.org learn to see this brand new
curriculum so the very first project we
have is a role playing game this is
where you're going to learn the basics
of JavaScript and also just the basics
of programming in general so learning
how to work with functions and variables
and IFL statements and loops and so much
more so let's go ahead and start the
project and this is what you're actually
going to build it's a role playing game
called Dragon repeller it so you can
make certain decisions in the game like
going to the store you can buy some
health right here and you can see that
it updates up here using JavaScript you
can buy a weapon it will show you which
weapons you have um and then if you
don't have enough money to buy something
then it will also show you that and so
this is what is known as a condition and
you're going to learn how to do that in
JavaScript in this project and then you
can go back you can fight a dragon and
so you can learn how to dynamically hide
and show HTML elements using JavaScript
and let's see we're attacking it and
unfortunately we didn't win we died so
we could repl replay the game reset it
and start all over again and so you can
play for multiple rounds right there
there's also a hidden secret Easter egg
inside here and an additional game that
you can play and so that's just a little
preview of what you're going to be
building for this very first project and
so for step one you're actually going to
start off with a complete Blank Slate as
you can see here you're going to start
with the HTML boilerplate code and build
out the basic HTML structure then you're
going to move into the CSS for styling
then you're actually going to jump into
the JavaScript which is around step 15
or so and so this helps you understand
how HTML CSS and JavaScript work
together to build interactive web
applications right there so that's why
we started off with just a complete
Blank Slate so you can connect all three
of those languages together right there
and so the great thing about this
project is that there's tons of steps
right here so this is the largest
project that we have however that's
actually really good thing because when
you're learning programming you want to
have tons of repetition in order for the
concepts to actually stick and to feel
comfortable executing on these Concepts
right here so here's a sneak peek of the
code that you're going to be writing in
this first project right here and so
you're going to have tons of practice
learning how to work with objects and
arrays and loops and variables and
functions and so much more and you're
going to have practice just constantly
writing that out and that will able to
enable you excuse me to actually feel
more comfortable executing on these
Concepts cuz one of the common things
when people are First Learning is they
learn a concept they practice it once
and then they forget about it with this
project and all of the projects in the
curriculum you're constantly practicing
you're constantly repeating yourself
just so it really sticks with you in
that muscle memory right there so that
wraps it up for this very first project
on learning basic JavaScript by building
a role playing
game so for the second project in the
JavaScript curriculum is going to be the
calorie counter project and in this
project you're going to learn the basics
of form validation and so often times
when you're building out interactive web
applications you are going to be dealing
with some sort of user input and so this
is a gentle introduction on how do you
process that user input right there and
so let's take a look at the project and
so this is what you're actually going to
be building so you can set a daily calor
budget so let's just say I don't know
2,000 maybe and then here you have
different fields for breakfast lunch
dinner snacks and exercise and so what
you could do is you can select which uh
inputs you want so let's say I don't
know I want to start with lunch and add
an entry then that will uh show me the
inputs and then I can add let's say a
sandwich I have no clue I'll just put
200 and you can add as many entries as
you like so let's say maybe a breakfast
one and eggs
I don't know how many calories I'm
totally making up these numbers but you
get the point there so you can add as
many entries as you would like right
there so we got chips uh 120 and then
once you're done you can calculate the
remaining calories and scroll down and
it will take that daily amount that you
entered at the beginning and do some
basic Cal calculations there and you can
see either you have a surplus or a
deficit right there and then how many
calories you've consumed and budgeted
and burned and all that that fun stuff
right there so you're going to learn how
to do all of this stuff in this second
project right here and so similar to the
first project uh you are going to be
writing a little bit of HTML in CSS it's
we give you most of the HTML in CSS and
then you're going to start by adding the
form element um and then you're going to
jump into the JavaScript right there and
learn how to deal with user input how
can you tell if a user input is valid or
not what do you do in those situations
how do you communicate that to the user
Etc so this is a really cool project
there um that will build off of your
knowledge from the previous project and
introduce some new Concepts uh that you
can use in your own interactive
JavaScript applications so that wraps it
up for this intro to the second project
where you learn form validation by
building a calorie
counter so for the very third project in
the curriculum you're going to build
your very own music player so I think
this is a really cool project because
there's so many new JavaScript Concepts
that you're going to be learning and
building from and so let's take a look
at this and so you're going to build
your very own music player and the
playlist features the songs by none
other than Quincy Larson so these are
all of his original songs that he wrote
and performed himself and has lent his
songs over to this project so it's
really cool because you can play for the
very beginning and it will highlight the
correct song that's actually playing
you'll be able to pause the song and you
can notice here that we have these
yellow indicators to show if we're
playing or pausing or if we are starting
over if we're going to the next one
right there you can also see that it
correctly updates uh the song title
right here as well as the visual
indicator updates every single time we
move to a new song so you're going to
learn how to do that using JavaScript
you can also shuffle through the
different songs right here and so if we
press this a few times you can see that
the songs are correctly updating and
shuffling around you can also remove
songs from a playlist with this little
red icon uh this delete icon so if we
delete oops all the songs right here
then you have an option to actually
reset the playlist and when you do that
then it just populates the playlist with
the original songs so it's it's a really
cool project and you're going to learn a
ton by building this out so from this
point forward you're no longer going to
need to write out the HTML and CSS um
for these projects all that's just going
to be provided for you because we're
going to dive straight into the
JavaScript and so I hope you really
enjoy this project you learn a lot from
it and then maybe you can build from
there and add new features and kind of
make it your own little music player but
that wraps it up for this introduction
into the third project of the all new
JavaScript
curriculum
so the next project you are going to
learn how to work with the date object
in JavaScript by building a date
formatter so dates notoriously could be
a little bit tricky especially in
production level apps and you're dealing
with time zones and so it's still really
important though to learn the basics of
working with javascript's date object
and this particular object has different
properties on it like getting the month
and the year in hours and seconds and so
we're going to learn how to format
different dates using JavaScript so this
is a preview of what we're going to be
building here and so by default it's
going to show you the date format um the
current date here which is the 17th it's
December 17th
2023 right there so day month year but
then if we want to change the format to
year month day then it will just update
that particular format or we can change
it and show the month day year hours and
minutes and it will show you that format
as well so you can kind of just toggle
between these different options right
here and um you're going to learn how to
do that so this is a shorter project
compared to the first three that we
looked at but it's still a really good
introduction and how to work with the
date object and as I mentioned earlier
all the HTML and CSS will be provided
for you in this project so you can just
jump straight in to the JavaScript and
that wraps it up for this intro for the
date formatter
project so the next project we're going
to take a look at is the palindrome
Checker and this is actually the first
certification project that we have seen
so far in the curriculum so the first
four projects were actually the practice
projects and that's where you were LED
step by step and learned new JavaScript
Concepts but the certification projects
right there you're building from scratch
and you're actually going to be given a
set of user stories that your project
needs to include and be able to pass all
of these tests right here um in order to
collect the certification so there's a
total of five certification projects and
this is the first one we're taking a
look at now in terms of building this
out before we take a look at what we're
building where should you build it you
can either build it out inside the freeo
camp editor or you can build it out
locally if you have experience working
with something like Visual Studio code
or sublime or brackets or atom or
webstorm or whatever so if you want to
build it out locally that's totally cool
as long as you just copy and paste your
solution in here and then you're able to
pass all of the tests right here so
let's take a look at what we're actually
going to be building so this is the demo
project right here and so a palindrome
is a word that could be spelled the same
front and back so an example of this
would be the word I e ye because it's
spelled the same forwards and backwards
so the main functionality that you need
to implement in the certification
project is if a user doesn't Supply any
input and just clicks on this check
button then an alert should show up and
say hey you need to supply something the
other thing is we need to be able to
determine if a word is a palindrome and
so they should be able to enter into a
word and then check if it is in fact a
palindrome and Supply that correct
result and if it's not a palindrome like
my name well then it should also
correctly get that it's not a palindrome
and so that's the main functionality for
this certification project so a quick
note about the Styles here a lot of
people think that they have to copy the
Styles exactly for all these
certification projects and that's
actually not true it's encouraged that
you use your own styling so this is just
the styling that the freeo camp team
went with but you can style this however
you want to the main thing is the the
JavaScript functionality has to be there
and so don't worry about styling if
you're just like I don't want to use
these Styles that's totally fine this is
just the demo project you can use
whatever Styles you want to as long as
you have the core functionality that we
just talked about right there that is
what is required to pass the uh
certification right there so that wraps
it up for this project and we'll take a
look at the next
one for this next project we are going
to build build out a set of football
team cards so this project is going to
cover Concepts like working with object
D structuring object. freeze the map
method and so much more so let's take a
look at what the final project is going
to look like so here we have some team
stats and we have Team Argentina uh
football or American soccer um the year
1986 and then the head coach right here
and then we have a list of the players
for that respective team and so what
you're going to learn how to do the
functionality where that comes in is
actually this drop down menu so you can
filter through the players based off of
their nicknames or the position that
they play on the team so if we just want
to see players that actually have
nicknames there then it will filter
through that list and filter out the
ones that don't have nicknames and only
show the ones that do you could also
filter by position
forward and you can filter by position
midfielder and
Defender and then also uh goalkeeper
right there and so you can just kind of
keep filtering through all of these and
just dynamically update the list
depending on what you want to see and
then you can go back to looking at all
of the different players and so that's
the JavaScript functionality that we are
going to be focused on right there so
this is a great project to kind of
practice more working with objects and
then how to get information from those
objects and then also to filter through
the the objects and dynamically display
the different player cards on the screen
so that wraps it up for this intro and
then we're going to jump into the very
next
project so for this next project you are
going to learn how to work with local
storage by building a to-do application
so local storage is a feature provided
by the browser where you can save data
in the browser and you can leave your
web application and come back to it and
that data will still be saved in there
so you're going to learn how to work
with the get and set methods for local
storage and you're going to learn that
by building a to-do application and
to-do applications are great uh when
you're first learning because you're
going to learn the basics of crud
operations and crud stands for create
read update and delete there so let's
take a look at the
project so it starts off as just a blank
slate we haven't added anything yet I
can add a new task and just say
recording a video I can add a date if I
want to so here's today's date and then
I can say something like recording a
video today cool add task and then it
will just save that inside the list of
task so I have the option to edit and if
I want to say recording an awesome video
right now to show my excitement I can
update that task and then it will
actually update that um like so you can
also delete tasks you can add multiple
tasks and we've also have this feature
where let's say I'm adding a task and
then I change my mind and if I click the
X out where there's data here it will
ask me hey are you sure do you want to
change uh remove this because you're
going to lose your changes and then you
can prompt it and say yes I'm totally
sure
um and so this is great and and one of
the things here is that if I try to
refresh the page then it will show the
local storage that I was talking about
where even though I did a manual refresh
right there it still had my original
data and so that is the local storage
portion that I was talking about earlier
where you can actually manually leave or
refresh the page and come back and it's
saved in your local storage so you're
going to see what all of that is about
so that's an introduction into this
project on learning local storage by
building a to-do
application for this next project you
are going to learn all about recursion
by building out a decimal to Binary
converter so recursion is often one of
those topics that could be really
confusing at first and it took me a
really long time to kind of wrap my head
around it because often times people
refer to it as a function that calls
itself and until you really understand
what's happening with the call stack
sometimes it's just really confusing but
this is a popular technique used to
break down a larger complex problem and
break it down into smaller sub problems
so you can solve it and so we're going
to teach recursion by building out a
decimal to Binary converter and so the
decimal number system base 10 0-9
numbers is probably the one that you're
most familiar with but then we also have
the binary number system which is a base
2 system made up of zeros and ones and
this project goes into a little bit more
detail on the different number systems
as you're building out this project so
let's take a look at the project itself
so here if you don't provide anything
then an alert shows up and says hey I'm
expecting a decimal number so if I
actually provided a number like 10 and
convert it it's going to convert it into
the binary representation of the decimal
10 so in order to see the animation here
we actually have to test this out with
the number five and what we've done here
is to try to illustrate what's happening
within the call STC when you're working
with um recursion so I'm going to click
on the convert
number and it's meant to represent the
what's happening on your call stack here
and we're going to go into more detail
when you actually go through this
project what all of this text is
actually meaning here but we wanted to
create an animation to kind of
illustrate what's happening when you're
writing recursive functions and
illustrate that on the call stack so
that's the main purpose behind this
particular project is to learn the
basics of recursion and build out a
small little animation uh to just better
illustrate how recursion works with the
call stack and that wraps it up for this
introduction and we'll jump into the
next
project so for this next project you are
going to build out a Roman numeral
converter and this is actually the
second certification project in the
curriculum and so similar to the first
one here you're going to be given a set
of directions a complete Blank Slate so
for this Roman numeral it gives you a
quick chart here between uh popular
Roman numerals and the Arabic numerals
on the side right here and your job is
that a user should be able to input um
an Arabic uh numeral and then you
convert it to a Roman numeral so that's
the whole purpose of this certification
project and there's a whole list of user
stories that we have right here and you
have to make sure to implement all 11
and run the test and make sure that
every single test is passing and then
it's encouraged to give your own style
so let's take a look at the demo project
right here and so if you try to convert
nothing it will say please enter an
actual number we're using the number
input here which has some basic
validation as well so if I input the
number 12 and convert it then it will
convert it to a Roman numeral and if I
do something like the number four then
it will keep converting it and because
we're using the number input then I
can't input just regular um you know
letters like my name or something like
that because obviously that's not going
to translate over to a Roman numeral and
so that's the whole purpose of this
project right here and so you have to
design an algorithm that takes in a
decimal number there and then converts
it over to a Roman numeral and outputs
it and again just like the other project
in terms of The Styling you don't need
to copy the styling you can use your own
Styles it's actually encouraged for you
to use your own Styles the main thing is
that you have to have the functionality
so we should be able to input a number
and it outputs the correct Roman numeral
so you have to design the correct
algorithm for that and that wraps it up
for this introduction into the Roman
numeral
converter
for this next project we are going to
learn the basics of algorithmic thinking
and different sorting algorithms by
building out a number sorter so in
computer science there's a few popular
sorting algorithms that you can use to
sort a list of numbers and so some of
these would include bubble sort or
insertion sort selection sort quick sort
and so many more so it's really
important to start learning basic data
structures and algorithms um to help you
build your programs as well as being
prepared for technical interviews when
you get ready to apply for a job and so
this first uh project right here on
algorithmic thinking is going to
introduce you to some popular sorting
algorithms that you will run into in
your typical intro to computer science
class so let's take a look at the actual
project right here and so we have a few
different inputs of random numbers here
and we can change uh the different
numbers and sort them in whatever order
we want to and when we click on the sort
method then it will just sort it from
smallest to largest and we can keep just
randomly uh sorting everything and then
it will just update right here but the
main part for this project is that
you're going to focus on three different
popular sorting algorithms so the first
one is the bubble sort algorithm and
then you're also going to learn about
selection sort and insertion sort so
you're going to build out all of these
algorithms by hand to learn how each one
works and compare each of them and
sorting a list of numbers from smallest
to largest so that wraps it up for this
introduction and I'll catch you in the
next
video for this next project you are
going to learn how to work with more
intermediate and advanced JavaScript
methods by building out a statistics
calculator so some of these important
methods that you're going to be working
with in this project are going to be the
map and filter and reduce method in
JavaScript so you're going to get tons
of practice working with these different
higher order functions and so in this
project you're going to build out a
statistics calculator and you're going
to be working with different
calculations to calculate the mode and
the median and the variance and so much
more and the project will go into depth
on how to do all of that so let's take a
look at the actual project so this is
the final project uh that you're going
to build out so it just gives a brief
introduction into what all of these uh
different calculations that you're going
to be working with like the what a mean
is and a median and a variance and all
of that stuff uh but basically what
you're going to be doing is you can
enter in a list of numbers and calculate
that and it will calculate the different
you know the mean the median the mode
range variance and standard deviation
and so you can list in whatever numbers
that you want want to right there and so
if I start to change it up and let's see
let's do a different list of numbers
then it will update those different
calculations right there and so this is
a really good project to kind of wrap
your head around more advanced U methods
especially the reduced method I think
for a lot of people when they're first
being introduced to the reduced method
sometimes they understand the basis
basics of it but uh working a little bit
more with it and understanding how all
that works in combination with like map
filter and other different methods it's
really important to kind of wrap your
head around some of these higher order
functions and how you can use them
within your program and so that's the
whole purpose of this statistics
calculator so that wraps it up for this
introduction and I will see you in the
next
video for this next project we are going
to learn about functional programming by
building a spreadsheet application and
so functional programming is an approach
in software development where you
organize your code by breaking it down
into smaller functions and this approach
is meant to help you build out more
complex applications so it's just a
different way of approaching than
designing and organizing your code and
so we're going to build out a
functioning spreadsheet application
where you can do a variety of
mathematical operations and we're going
to walk you through how to interact
within the spreadsheet and how to
actually execute these uh expressions
right here so let's go ahead and take a
look so this is actually what the
project looks like it's just a blank
spreadsheet uh so imagine like you know
Google spreadsheets and stuff like that
uh but I've actually inputed a few
numbers here just to illustrate a few of
the calculations that you could do and
so to make a calculation for any of
these cells here you could start
prefixing it with the uh equals sign and
if we wanted to let's say add two
numbers from a cell let's say we wanted
to add A3 and uh B4 so we could do A3 +
B4 and hit enter and then it will do the
correct calculation I've also uh added a
couple of functions right here so we can
check if everything within a range
between uh A2 and A5 if that is in fact
um all even and so if we take a look no
we do have number 15 which is odd so
it's going to return false right there
and so you can do uh these different
calculations and we're going to walk
through every single calculation through
the step-by-step project when you're
building it out there and you're going
to learn how to make this uh spreadsheet
interactive and so when it first starts
then it's just going to give you the
basic uh blank spreadsheet and the HTML
and CSS and then it's your job to add
all of that interactive portion using
JavaScript all right so that wraps it up
for this intro and I'll see you in the
next
project
for this next project we are going to
learn all about regular Expressions by
building out a spam filter so regular
expressions or reject for short are
patterns that you can use to match and
search for text so sometimes when you're
learning regular Expressions it can be a
little bit complicated because they're
these weird funny symbols but with
enough practice then you start to get a
little bit more comfortable with regular
expressions and the good news is there's
tons of online tools like Rex 10 one to
help you build out your regular
Expressions so let's take a look at the
project that you're going to build and
so we're going to build out a spam
filter so there's a list of phrases that
you are going to need to check for using
regular Expressions so some of the
phrases are going to be like free money
because no one offers up free money and
it should spit out hey this is a spam
message but if you say something like hi
there well that's not necessarily a Spam
message and so it should be able to
check the text and say say this looks
like spam or it doesn't now this is a
very basic spam filter um but it's just
meant to kind of introduce you into
regular expressions and how to start to
work with them for matching and
searching text right there and so
there's going to be a list of phrases
that you're going to need to check and
that wraps it up for this introduction
into regular Expressions by building a
spam
filter for this next project you are
going to learn how to build out a
telephone validator and this is actually
the third certification project in the
curriculum and so this is a project
where you're going to check for a valid
United States phone number and it gives
a few examples of valid entries but
basically a United States phone number
has the country code of one followed by
a three-digit area code followed by a 7
digigit phone number so some valid uh
phone numbers can have dashes some will
have parentheses like this some will
have a mixture of parentheses and dashes
some could just be numbers without the
country code so all of these are
examples of valid numbers and your job
is to create a telephone validator where
a user inputs a number and then the
output should be this is a valid Us
number or not so let's take a look at
the uh demo project and again you don't
need to build out this actual style this
is just for the demo you could use
whatever styles that you want to for the
certification project but uh if you were
to not input anything then you should
have the functionality where it alerts
the user to say hey you need to provide
something so we can check it and inside
this input here you can have uh so this
is a valid United States number you can
check it and it should return valid Us
number followed by the input that the
user provided but if I provide something
like yeah my name obviously that is not
not a valid United States number if I
just put in just random numbers like
this this is not a valid United States
number so that is the basics of this um
project right here is that you should be
able to check whatever the user input
and output whether it's a valid Us
number or clearly not a valid number and
you can also clear the input as well and
and add new ones so that's the basic
functionality that you have to build out
for this certification
project and that wraps it up for this
introduction and I'll see you in the
next
project for this next project you are
going to learn the basics of working
with objectoriented programming by
building a shopping cart project so
objectoriented programming is a way that
you can design your code and build it
out using a series of objects and
classes and so that differs from the
functional programming style where you
build out and design your project
objects around smaller functions and so
we're going to learn how to work with
classes within the con uh context of
JavaScript we're also going to learn to
work with the this keyword as well as um
so many other new Concepts in this
project so let's go ahead and start the
project and this is what you're going to
build and so it's a little desserts page
and you can add certain things to the
cart uh so up here we have our little
shopping cart which is empty so you can
toggle that um on and off so you're
going to learn how to do that with
JavaScript if you want to add something
like let's say a French
macaroon then you can open the cart and
you can see that it has been added with
the correct price um and then it will
show you the total number of items in
your cart as well as the subtotal the
tax and the total and so you're going to
build out a class right here and have
different methods for calculating the
total and the taxes and all that fun
stuff and if you want to clear out your
cart then it will ask you or are you
sure and if so then you can clear it out
you can hide it again uh but you can add
so many different things to your cart
and it will update so we have four
chocolate macaroons and then strawberry
ice cream and if we do show cart then
you can see that it shows the quantity
of four as well as the ice cream and it
does the correct calculations right here
and so that's the basics of this project
and it's in your first introduction into
working with classes in the context of
JavaScript right there and the this
keyword and spread operator and so much
more so that wraps it up for this
introduction and I'll see you in the
next
project for this next project you're
going to continue working and learning
objectoriented programming by building a
platformer game so this is a really cool
game to uh just kind of solidify your
knowledge of what you learned in the
previous project with the shopping cart
on how to work with objectoriented
programming and classes in inside
JavaScript so here I've uh pulled up the
final step and if I show the preview
here I just want to make sure that we
have plenty of room to work with and so
this is our platformer game and you are
going to build this out so it has a
little start screen right here and when
we click on the start screen then we can
use the keyboard controls and we can
move our player we can jump up and down
um so you're going to learn how to build
out that functionality then you can jump
on the different Platformers you're also
going to learn how to build out this
kind of uh moving giving us illusion
right here that we're moving forward and
backwards and whatnot you're going to
learn how to build that out and then we
also have these like yellow uh
checkpoints and so when you hit a
checkpoint then a little message pops up
and says hey cool good for you and so
you can kind of go throughout this
platform game hitting the different
checkpoints using your keyboard controls
on your computer um and then once you
reach the final checkpoint then uh the
game is over and so this is a great way
for you to kind of think about different
types of algorithms like Collision
detection algorithms and how to move
throughout the game how to interact with
the different platforms and whatnot um
and what to do when a uh the player hits
one of the checkpoints all of that fun
stuff you're going to learn in this game
and this is just going to help you
solidify your approach to
object-oriented programming in
JavaScript so that wraps it up for this
introduction and I'll see you in the
next
project for this project you're going to
continue to learn more about algorithmic
thinking and game design by building a
dice game and so some of the algorithms
that you're going to be building are
when the user rolls the dice um can they
get a full house or a small or large
straight or three of a kind and so
you're going to be building out all of
those different types of algorithms and
dis displaying and awarding the correct
points based on the type of dice that
they rolled so let's go ahead and take a
look at the project preview so this is
the full project so we have this show
and hide rules button and so you can
actually show the rules and read through
them and you can see what kind of points
you can get and then you can hide them
so you're going to learn about that
toggle functionality and you actually
learned about it in an earlier project
with the shopping cart so really you're
just going to kind of review how to talk
on and off right there uh but basically
the way that this game works is there's
a total of six rounds and so you can
roll the dice up to three times per
round so I'm going to roll the dice here
and you get a random list of numbers
between one and six representing the
typical numbers you find on a dice and
then depending on the combination of
numbers there you can either get a three
of a kind four of a kind Full House
small straight which is 1 2 3 4 or a
large straight which is 1 2 3 4 five or
you can get none of the above so in this
case I didn't really get anything so I
could roll again and in this case I got
a small straight so I can actually
select that and keep that score or I
could try rolling again to see if I get
a large straight but I'm actually going
to keep that score and then you can move
on to the next round and so you can
depending on the random selection of
numbers there then you can get one of
these scores select which one you want
to keep and we'll move a little bit
quicker here so there's a total of uh
six rounds so I'm going to keep oh
playing and also another thing is if you
press the button more than three times
cuz you're only allowed three rolls per
round then we have this little alert
message that shows you so I didn't
really get anything that last round uh
but you can kind of just and this is all
random right here just like you know in
an actual dice game oh cool I got a
small straight and so this is the last
round so if I keep that score then you
want to have that game logic to actually
end the game after six rounds show them
the total score when you click okay it
automatically resets the game and you
start all over so you're going to build
out all of that dice game logic and
build out your algorithmic thinking
about what happens when the user does
this how do I build out these different
algorithms for the different cases like
building a full a full house or a small
stay or a uh three of a kind or a four
of a kind and how do I show the correct
uh not prices but correct scores um and
then total all of that up at the end and
so that's what you're really going to be
building in this dice game project so
that wraps it up for this introduction
and I will see you in the next
project for this next project you are
going to build out a cash register and
this is actually the fourth
certification project in the curriculum
so similar to the other ones you're
going to build everything from scratch
all the HTML CSS and JavaScript and
we'll go into the functionality in just
a second right here but you'll be given
a set of directions um here's a little
bit of a chart um as well as a demo link
and a set of user stories that you have
to pass in order to pass this project
and get the certification right there
and so let's take a look at this demo
project and similar to all the other
certification projects all the demo
projects you do not need to replicate
these Styles this is just the styles
that the Freo Camp team came up with you
can come up with whatever Styles you
want to but it's important that you have
the exact functionality because that's
what we're going to be testing you on so
this is the project that you are going
to build out and the basic functionality
is as follows is we have an item number
right here and then we have the list of
change inside the cash register broken
up by the amount of pennies nickels
dimes Etc and so I should be able to
enter in a price let's say I don't know
$5 and click purchase it it should give
me back the correct amount of change
just like in the real world I can also
buy new items so this one is for $200 59
and so if I do exact change $200
59 and click purchase then you should
display a message saying no change due
because I paid with exact cash just like
in the real world and then if I try to
be obnoxious and give um you know a
really large amount based on you know
$10,000 here then it should say
insufficient funds because the you know
this is not a bank right like the cash
register if you try to do that at a
grocery store that obviously wouldn't
work if you tried to give somebody
$10,000 paying for $82 worth of
groceries they probably won't have
enough cash I would imagine right and so
you should have this insufficient funds
message showing replicating what it
would actually happen so if you try to
give them too much money and they don't
have enough change to give you that is
is the correct Behavior right there so
you can filter through just like the
different items and test out those
different scenarios but that's the basic
functionality that you need to build for
this certification project and so the
key things are remembering what happens
if the user gives you exact change what
happens if the user gives you too much
money do you have insufficient funds in
your cash register and then what happens
if the user gives you just enough and
you need you do have enough uh change to
give them so those are the different
scenarios that you need to consider in
this certification project all right so
that wraps it up for this introduction
and I'll see you in the next
project for this next project you are
going to learn how to work with the
fetch API and you're going to learn
about asynchronous programming in this
project by building a free Camp
authors's Page and so up until this
point you've mainly been working with
synchronous programming and this is
going to be your first introduction in
working with the fetch API where you're
going to be able to fetch data um and
display the data on the page you're
going to deal with situation on if the
the data that you're fetching if that
request fails how do you handle that
situation what is a synchronous
programming all of that stuff will be
covered in this project and it's really
important to understand how to work with
different API how to get the results how
to display it on the page especially as
a front-end developer um because you
will be tested on that in your technical
interviews and you will be doing that a
lot um on the actual job itself so this
is going to be your first introduction
into working with external apis so let's
go ahead and take a look at the actual
project so this is the project and so we
have a list of author cards and these
are actual free Camp authors found on
the freeo camp news page so we have
Quincy we have myself um we have itara
Jennifer colade etc etc and you can
actually uh load more authors right here
and so you're going to learn how to do
that because sometimes when you're
working with these apis you don't want
to fetch everything and load everything
all at once because that could be
overwhelming what if you had thousands
of results and so you're going to start
to learn how to work with
pagination and that's what that load
more button is is that you can load the
results and display a certain amount
whether it's 10 at a time or 25 at a
time instead of just displaying
everything and so you've you've probably
been used to working with page on
websites especially like e-commerce
websites and stuff like that with
different product pages so this is an
introduction into that and so you'll be
able to see the different authors and
fetch more authors and all of this data
is being pulled from an API and you're
going to learn exactly what an API is
it's going to go into depth on how to
work with that and how to work with the
fetch API and all of that fun stuff uh
but this is the basics of the project is
how do you work with an API how do you
get that information back how do you
actually display it on the page and then
what happens if you're not able to fetch
the results from that API how do you
handle those edge cases and errors um
inside your code so that's a basic
introduction into working with
asynchronous programming and the fetch
API by building out a free c-amp
author's
page so for this project you're going to
continue learning about asynchronous
programming and working with async and a
Away by building out a free c-amp forum
leaderboard project and so this is
basically just a continuation from the
previous project learning how to work
with the fetch API learning how to get
data in and display it on the page but
this is just going to uh expand on your
knowledge from the previous project here
so let's take a look at what this
project is all about so this is
basically just a reproduction of the
latest topics that you'll find on the
actual Forum so if I go to the actual
Forum site this is the Freo Camp Forum
where you can ask questions and have
discussions with other Learners and so
you're basically just building out this
latest post page and it pulls in the
latest 30 post um right there in real
time so this Maps exactly to what we're
seeing on the actual site and so what
we're doing is we're pulling data from
an API and we're uh pulling in that data
and then displaying it on the page and
so we're pulling out only certain parts
this data we're pulling out the topics
here the user avatars the ones who have
been participating in the conversations
we can see the number of replies the
views we can also see the last
activities so in this case uh 33 minutes
ago right there so you're going to learn
how to do all of that and build out all
the
functionality uh as well so the uh
Styles will be provided for you but
you're going to learn how to pull all
this information and then also you're
going to be able to click on a link
right there there um and and it will in
theory take you to the actual Forum page
but this is what you're going to be
building out is you're going to learn
how to pull information from an API how
to display it on the page and arrange it
in this order and it's just a
continuation of what you've been working
with in the previous project with the
freeo camp authors page so that wraps it
up in for this introduction to the
leaderboard project and then we'll move
on to the last and final
project
so for the very last project in the
curriculum you're going to build out a
Pokemon Search application and this is
also the last certification project in
the curriculum so just like all the
other certification projects you're
given a clean slate so you're going to
write all the HTML CSS in JavaScript
yourself so you're going to be given a
list of directions a demo application
which we'll take a look at in a second
and then a list of user stories right
here and you have you have to make sure
to pass every single one of these user
stories um and test it right here run
the test and if everything passes then
you're able to submit your project so
let's take a look at the demo project so
just like all the other certification
projects you do not need to use the same
Styles as the free camp demo project
it's actually encouraged to just use
your own Styles but you do have to have
the same functionality so what this
application is doing is that you're able
to search for Pokemon a database of
Pokemon and where all this Pokemon is
coming from is a Pokemon API and so your
work that you did with the fream author
page and leaderboard projects is going
to prepare you to do this certification
project so you're going to be able to
enter in a Pokemon name or an ID number
so if I enter in Pikachu for example
then it will search through that API and
it will pull out the correct one and it
will list out the name the ID um and
certain attributes right here and there
different stats and then you can also
search by um ID number so let's say uh
three and you can search and then it
will dynamically update as you can see
right here for Venusaur and it will just
show their correct attributes so as long
as you provide a valid ID or uh a PO
Pokemon name but you should also have an
alert so obviously I am not a Pokemon so
then you should see an alert that says
Pokémon not found and so what it's doing
is it's just searching through that that
API the list of Pokémon that it has and
if it can't find it you should have an
alert functionality to let the user know
that that's not a valid um entry right
there so we'll just go back to three
back to Venusaur all right so that wraps
it up for the entire JavaScript
curriculum I hope you found this video
helpful I hope that you are excited to
jump into this curriculum and again this
curriculum assumes that you're an
absolute beginner and so I know I kind
of went through and showed you different
intros and there might have been points
in this video where like oh my gosh am I
I'm going to build that how am I going
to know how to do that I promise you
we're going to start off really small
small and slow with the roleplaying game
learning the basics and then you just
build from there and you learn more
intermediate in advanced concepts and
then it will all culminate with these uh
certification projects where you're
going to build on your own all right
thank you so much for watching and happy
coding